[Music]
hi everyone it's charlie you guys have
probably noticed how there are a lot of
scenes in the game of thrones season 8
trailer that seemed to reference scenes
from game of thrones season 1 episode 1
the pilot episode because this is the
final season of the main show there'll
probably be a lot of big moments
during season 8 that will pay reference
to big scenes from the pilot episode
we already know about a couple big ones
because of all the trailers and teasers
that we've got so i'll just break this
down top 10 style
there's a new round of the game of
thrones book giveaway too all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video
no worries about spoilers in this video
we'll just be talking about scenes that
we've seen in the trailers and the
teasers so far and what the producers
have talked about
starting with number 10 the actual title
of the episode they haven't released the
official titles for any of the season 8
episodes yet
but the title of the pilot episode was
winter is coming
what bigger callback could they have to
that episode in season 8 than calling
episode 1
something with winter in the title they
already used the winds of winter as the
title of the season 6 finale during that
episode jon said winter has come early
prediction then they should call season
8 episode 1
either winter has come winter is here is
also a quote that sansa said but that
doesn't sound quite as epic but it would
also be acceptable
as for the title of the other episodes
they typically don't actually pick the
title of the episodes till after the
scripts are finished and they try to
draw on as many book references as
possible
in something that pays reference to the
different storylines
like for instance season seven episode
two is stormborn because they were
paying reference to daenerys name
daenerys stormborn the storm that
happened on the night of her birth
around dragonstone that almost destroyed
an entire fleet
while at the end of that episode euron
destroyed most of their fleet
some of them are a little more literal
like the winds of winter which is the
title of the next book then sometimes
they lean in the other direction like
season seven episode three which was
queen's justice which is mostly just
reference to cersei
daenerys's justice as well as the queen
of thorns
tell cersei i want her to know it was me
so i'm not expecting them to try and
shoehorn in like
really huge book references to all the
season eight episode titles but we'll
find out pretty soon
number nine ed tormund and beric
dinderian
have a scene during the trailer where it
looks like they're either at castle
black or somewhere else
maybe they also have a white walker
related scene entering this room here
there's really no other reason for them
to have a scene at the wall with tormund
barrick in the night's watch other than
to carry things forward from that moment
in season 7 episode vii
when the night king brought down the
wall they ran from eastwatch by the sea
in terror and the white walker started
marching south that would be a callback
reference to the opening scene of the
pilot when waymar royce will
and garrett found all those white walker
symbols north of the wall
even though obviously they're not going
north of the wall in the season a
trailer scene here
fun easter egg here too waymar royce
here in this scene is yon royce's son
who you've been seeing the last couple
of seasons up at winterfell
sansa actually mentioned waymar royce to
yon royce during season 4 when she went
to the vale with littlefinger
and even though we haven't talked a lot
about the game of thrones prequel tv
series that's supposed to air next year
in the unaired game of thrones pilot
episode that character weymar royce was
played by jamie campbell bauer
and he was just cast as a new character
in the game of thrones prequel series we
don't know who he's playing but it's
just sort of closing the loop just a
nice callback to that unaired pilot in
the weymar royce character
because they found those white walker
symbols that looked a lot like the
symbols that john and daenerys found in
the caves at dragonstone maybe they find
something that references the white
walkers at castle black number eight
there was the scene of the stark family
in winterfell with ned stark and catelyn
watching the children practice archery
in the yard
arya shows off for them after getting
really bored with the needlework that
sansa is doing
there's a scene of arya inspecting the
dragonglass in the trailer talking about
death like they're getting ready for the
white walkers to come she's just showing
everyone how badass she is
that would be a nice call back reference
to arya showing off for everyone with
the archery in the pilot episode
i'm assuming that a lot of these
callback scenes and references to scenes
from the pilot episode 2 won't be
happening in the same order in the
episode because i wouldn't expect aria
to have any kind of meeting with gendry
talking about dragonglass before jon
snow and daenerys arrive
because gendry is heading to winterfell
with jon snow and daenerys so he
wouldn't arrive before them
you remember too that when ned and
catelyn were watching them from above
ned stark said the words winter is
coming
tell bran he's coming too
ned ten is too young to see such things
he won't be a boy forever
and winter is coming they'll also
probably be lots of easter eggs in the
things that people say during season
eight there will be references to things
that people said during the pilot
episode
and you also remember sort of the roles
that people have adopted now so like
right now
sansa spends a lot of time walking
around watching people from above
like catelyn did she even starts to look
a lot like catelyn she modeled her hair
after her back during season six
so expect a lot of catelyn stark sansa
stark references during the first
episode as well
there was the scene where they all find
the direwolves the producers did confirm
the ghost would be part of season 8 even
though he technically
doesn't appear in the trailer as far as
we can tell there's a couple scenes
where it seems like direwolves are
running with the dothraki during the big
battle but when johnson with daenerys
come back it would make sense that jon
had some sort of reunion
with ghost regardless of how they use
him throughout the entire season
hopefully he survives i don't want to
see him die during that big battle
but number six there was a scene of ned
stark in the godswood polishing his
valyrian sword
ice catelyn walks in and says she's
always felt like an outsider they talk
about the old gods and the new gods
there is a scene during the trailer
where it seems like jon snow is standing
at the heart tree but i'm also expecting
bran stark to spend a lot of time there
too just because that's where a lot of
his power is
isaac hempstead wright even said that
bran has sort of gotten more comfortable
with his abilities
so he's better able to interact with
people he won't be quite as much of a
turnip as he was during season seven
the godswood is one of the most powerful
locations at winterfell
it has all this deep mythology so
usually when they have scenes there
they're talking about the gods they're
talking about really really big ideas
so anytime you see jon snow visit one of
the biggest locations like the crips for
instance
usually it's when the story is dealing
with really really big ideas
so number five there was a scene of
robert baratheon arriving like the big
procession
that callback is obviously when jon snow
and daenerys are marching their army to
winterfell with the dragons through
wintertown here but also within that
scene while they were rolling up to the
gates there was a scene of arya climbing
up on the back of the wagon watching
them march by with a smile on her face
just like the scene we see of arya
during the season 8 trailer watching
daenerys and jon snow
march by washi smiles looking up at the
dragons
there was also the scene of bran
climbing up on the walls to watch them
march in just like the little boys
climbing up on the walls in wintertown
to watch them march through
four there was the actual introduction
greetings scene where robert baratheon
walks up with cersei to greet ned stark
catelyn and the stark children so
obviously that's a reference to this
scene of jon introducing daenerys to
sansa brienne and even though you can't
see everyone that's standing next to
them here i'm hoping that arya samwell
and maybe bran is in his wheelchair
there too but even if bran isn't down
there
maybe he'll warg a raven and watch them
enter that way three there's the scene
of ned stark and robert baratheon in the
crypts of winterfell going to visit
lyanna stark's statue and reminisce
about robert's rebellion
and him talking about killing rhaegar
targaryen every night i kill him in my
sleep
in my dreams i kill him every night
it's done you grace
targaryens are gone ned stark just
sitting there nodding his head being
quiet keeping his mouth shut about the r
plus l equals j of it all there are a
few scenes that we've seen in the crypts
of winterfell and all the trailers and
teasers so at some point during the
episode or
maybe during episode two jon snow will
probably visit the crips
like i said i'm not expecting every
single moment that they reference from
the pilot episode to happen during
episode one some of them might happen in
episode two some might happen later in
the season
but two there was the scene of tyrion at
the brothel with roz and even though i
don't expect tyrion to spend as much
time at brothels anymore
they'll probably have some scene with
him referencing the way that he used to
be or just
joking about how much he used to like
doing that and number one even though
daenerys did get married at the end of
the pilot episode i don't expect her and
jon snow to get married
during the end of this first episode of
season eight the story is nowhere near
something like that yet
there's been so much foreshadowing about
the future of their relationship
regardless of who you think is gonna
live and who's gonna die
the next logical step would be for the
realms most eligible bachelor who may or
may not have already impregnated
the realm's most eligible bachelorette
to formalize their union with a marriage
but they haven't dropped the rhaegar
targaryen lyanna stark bomb yet
the night king hasn't attacked yet they
haven't dealt with cersei yet and
daenerys hasn't learned that she's
potentially
pregnant again so i don't think that the
show would do a jon snow daenerys
wedding before any of those other
big wtf moments so just remember that a
lot of the references to the pilot
episode
might happen later in the season you
guys may have also heard about the game
of thrones wrap party after they
finished filming last
year for the cast and crew the
decorations for the rap
party had a targaryen and stark symbol
combined so it doesn't confirm that
there's going to be any kind of jon snow
daenerys marriage this season
but i'll just let you speculate based on
that it just seems like everything is
slowly heading in that direction but
we'll have to wait for some more
evidence in the actual episodes to let
us know whether or not they're going to
pay that off
let me know in the comments which other
moments from the pilot episode do you
think that they're going to reference
during season 8 or even during season
eight episode one
there'll be more game of thrones videos
coming later this week so leave all your
requests in the comments below and
congratulations to ben suolo you're the
giveaway winner from my last big game of
thrones video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your details
click here for all my season 8 night
king and white walker easter eggs and
click here for that brand new season 8
behind the scenes video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you